[Music]
[Music]
under incessant air and artillery attack
the people of kharkiv in eastern ukraine
have seen their homes destroyed and
their lives turned upside down when
russia invaded their country few could
have imagined the brutality that would
ensue or how hard it would be for
civilians to survive but for those who
have stayed in this shattered city
somehow humanity prevails this is their
story
[Music]
this is hakeev ukraine's second largest
city
its once graceful center its museums
shops and government buildings are now
bomb scarred monuments to a savage war
less than 30 miles from the russian
border harkev was an early target when
the invasion began on february 24
ukrainian forces managed to halt that
thrust on the outskirts of the city but
ever since it's been under aerial and
artillery attack
[Music]
the north and east of the city have been
bombarded for weeks
m
russian frustration that being unable to
take the city now finds an outlet in
random destruction
[Music]
[Music]
firefighters have been called to a
street in the northern saltifica
district
and our rookie reporter is here to
record it
[Music]
before war i was running with my team
tremendous team a creative
social enterprise business
once it begins there
is the issue that you
or or try to do something one of the
pieces was to run and got a refugee but
we pick
in our team pick to
stay and do something at this time
basically
that first station i pick to be
a journalist and reporter i'm not a war
reporter of course i don't know how to
do this but it seems like i learn
at the moment young men are not being
asked to fight if they don't have any
combat experience or useful skills
the firefighters say he's filming with
know it's dangerous being here but they
remain
defiant but there's still a danger of
secondary shelling and sergi is told to
leave in a hurry
[Music]
my name is jerusalem
and
i was born and live in haku this is my
home
before the bar i was happy
on the day
the war began
i was waking up at 5 00 am
i heard
loud explosions
after a while i ran to the atm to
withdraw cash but while
i was standing in line
a bomb fell
two straight away from me
i will never forget that sound
24 year old yaroslav is one of sehi
prakapenko's guara media team
since the war began he and his family
have been sheltering in their second
floor apartment
he's been keeping a video diary
good morning it's
30 minutes past
11
um
16th day of the war
almost all the time we
sit in
between two walls in our house and
almost do nothing
it is
still
heavy
scared and
some kind of angry
i have
a headache
from loud sounds
s30k
and
almost all the day i was spent on the
floor between walls
on my
home
maybe that's all for right now good
night
and
the northern and eastern parts of the
city are under constant bombardment
[Music]
but elsewhere volunteers are helping to
keep people alive
hidden in the back streets of central
harkev this former hostel has been
converted into a community welfare
center
it goes by the name of hell's kitchen
but as the war continued international
aid began to arrive
hell's kitchen now provides food and
medication to over two and a half
thousand people daily
[Music]
and they even have a signature product
with a particular message embedded in
the crust
[Music]
the trident signifies that ukraine is
united and will fight on
[Music]
remember
the food produced here isn't just for
civilians it's hard to cook at the front
line and the hot meals they deliver to
their soldiers are crucial to the war
effort
at an international i.t company and
regularly traveled all over europe
his wife luda also worked in i.t but now
packs delivery boxes from six in the
morning to after midnight
despite the daily attacks the city
authorities have somehow kept essential
utilities operating
[Music]
loading up the van outside hell's
kitchen the volunteers are preparing for
another long and dangerous day
sir he and his camera are going along
for the ride
one of the centre's most active recruits
is andriy gosenko
until a few weeks ago he worked at
heartron a ukrainian aerospace company
he's now leading a rather different life
[Music]
me
by
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the volunteer team head up the five
flights of stairs to the aid of 86 year
old lydia roman ivna
yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
morning it's 11 a.m and 20th day of the
war
but yesterday it was
pretty loud day as the day before and
day before
today
my dad and my brother
they went
to the supermarket and buy some food
and now we're still sitting at our house
sometimes we
scream
to each
other
and
[Music]
trying to
[Music]
i hear some explosions
i don't know is it
is it record
and do you hear it
[Music]
also good news a couple days ago from my
colleagues
came some
results
so we shared
when it's free
and trying
to to be safe
a situation is like it was very
intensive shooting in kharkiv center
over the night
i know that several buildings is
destroyed
[Music]
one of those buildings houses one of
ukraine's most important art collections
[Music]
it was damaged when an adjacent police
and security headquarters were targeted
by a russian rocket
but indiscriminate firing is no
respecter of history or culture
well
[Music]
[Music]
art department at harkeev museum of the
arts
it's home to twenty five thousand rare
and valuable exhibits many of which
ironically are russian
specialists
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
before the war marina and her husband
lived just a few blocks away from the
museum
but their street and apartment was
heavily bombed and they had to move into
a shelter
she's been trying to come to terms with
what's happened
[Music]
is
[Music]
today
the largest market burning in havakev
this is not
clouds
this is smoke
[Music]
i don't know
if
there is somewhere safe in ukraine now
my friends say they hear
explosions getting close
and
and yeah i'm afraid that the russians
will enter the city because i don't know
what
will happen
and
what to do in this case
but i hope
it
doesn't happen
i wish
for peace
yaroslav and his family don't want to
voluntarily leave their house but for
others one place of at least partial
safety in hakeev is the city's metro
katya parashachanska and her partner
andriy fled here from their home in
northern saltivka
one of the city's worst affected
districts
[Music]
had a population of one and a half
million but over half of the inhabitants
have left
when the fighting began two and a half
thousand people took shelter in this one
metro station
now there are just seven hundred
julia zinko is one of those who stayed
but it's not a healthy environment
but at least every day volunteers bring
supplies to be distributed
blankets clothes and medicines
there's plenty of food and water
and julia has no plans to leave
[Music]
morning
it's
40 minutes after 11
uh 20 of march and
the day number 25
of the
wow
yesterday our electricity was turned off
and
there is no water either
it seems
like
some kind of
joke but
this is our life
and this is
our reality of survival
like the electricity supply the water
supply is erratic
when the water's on they fill every
available container and personal hygiene
becomes a luxury
yesterday wasn't turned on
the water and we used
all the waters that we
have on our base
but today
right now we have a little pressure
uh
i'm sitting on the balcony it's sunny
right now and i hear some
sounds
of spring
i can say
the
like birds have seen him
[Music]
and it's beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
like firefighters medics are in big
demand
andrey guzenko has had an urgent call
from one of his volunteers whose mother
mrs marinich has fallen during a bombing
attack
he's found a doctor and is taking him to
help
[Music]
the doctor quickly diagnoses a suspected
hip fracture
but there's little he can do
this makeshift boot splint is supposed
to stop the leg moving and protect the
hip
but the injury will have lasting
consequences
but it's the best the doctor can do in
the circumstances and the last call for
the team services before they head back
to their shelters
no one knows what the next weeks will
bring
but yaroslav has made a
decision me with my family
we think that if street fights starts
and
i hope
they don't start
if the russians try to enter the city
we will have to live
i have
a little back where
my
documents and
also some food
[Music]
and some stuff
which i
will need
in a case of leaving some
money
[Music]
it has become quiet now but
the fire of war is
continues to burn
for now
sergi has also decided to stay
but he too knows he may have to leave
eventually
you don't want to go even it's our job
basically we're gonna continue
reporting if russia would come
and ukrainian troops would not able to
to beat them
and
if the city fight and we'll start i
think it will be the
moment
when
we need to go
when war came to hakeev it changed
people's lives in ways none of them
could have foreseen
[Music]
but for each of them and the other
residents of this battered city under
siege
life somehow still goes on
[Music]
you